live from the headquarters of Ramsey
solutions it's the Dave Ramsey show
where dad is dumb
cash is king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice I'm Dave
Ramsey your host and this is a show that
shows you what to do and if you do it it
will work when it comes to your money
it's a pretty simple idea if you live on
less than you make you will have more
money if you live on a budget you will
have more money if you are more generous
you will have a tendency towards more
money if you save and invest you'll have
more money so your actions cause your
ability to win in different areas of
your life let's pretend you grew up in a
family of fat people
your mama's fat your daddy's fat your
granny's fat your Grandpa's fat
everybody's fat so it's in your DNA or
it's at least in the environment that
you grew up in at a minimum right
everybody's obese all around you you
have a real tendency towards obesity
what can we agree to that yeah I mean
you grew up in an environment of obesity
can you choose different habit patterns
than your family and affect that or are
you stuck are you just destined and
fatalistic and saying that's it I have
to be obese my family has always been
obese we're always gonna be obese
the such-and-such family they're the
obese family you're stuck is that the
case do you believe that if you do
you're what's called a fatalist you
believe you're stuck you believe you are
destined to losing I don't believe that
and this show is based on the fact that
I truly believe and I have data to prove
it that when people change their actions
because they have new information
because they have hope
when they change their actions they
change their results most of us agree
that when you plant something in the
ground you will grow that's something if
you put corn in the ground you will grow
corn don't be shocked - the corn comes
up instead of beans you put corn in the
ground the Bible says you reap what you
sow
what you plant is what's going to grow
in your life if you plant nothing you
know what happens in your backyard
weeds you know what happens in your life
when you plant nothing intentionally
weeds you don't accidentally get into
shape when you meet someone that has a
six-pack and they're completely cut
they're ripped they look like some of
the kind of mr. and mrs. universe that
was not an accident it's not an accident
they chose different food they chose
different exercise programs they chose
different volumes of food their choices
gave them a result money's the same way
no can you start out with a deficit
because of the neighborhood you grew up
in the family you grew up in the
background the way everybody around you
your belief system does it affect you
and uh does it start you in a hole yeah
some of us start out ahead of others but
you can still choose I don't care what
color you are I don't care whether
you're democrat or republican I don't
care if you're a Yankee or you were born
in God's country in the South I don't
care where you came from you can choose
different actions and thereby will
choose different results 100 percent of
time is it harder for some than others
yep is it easier for some than others
yep some people are smarter than other
people
some people are better-looking than
other people I'm stuck with a face for
radio that's why you don't see my
shining head on the Today Show I'm not
pretty enough we send Rachel to do that
I'm stuck with this that's fine though
I'm gonna work with what I got
it's the only face I got I got to work
with
that it's the only race I got I got to
work with it I can't change my race I
got to be this I'm a hillbilly I grew up
in hillbilly I'm happy to be a hillbilly
I just won't be a really rich hillbilly
shut up okay if you won't be a really
rich Yankee I'll help you I don't care
this is all about making different
decisions and here's the deal if you
figure out what poor people are doing
and you do that with money you're gonna
be poor people if you figure out what
rich people are doing with money and you
do that with money you're gonna
eventually be rich people if you're rich
and you do poor people stuff with money
you'll become poor if you're poor and
you do rich people stuff with money long
enough you will become wealthy
regardless of where you start your
actions will take you to a destination
some faster some slower but they will
take you to a destination so figure out
what rich people are doing figure out
what skinny people are doing if you
won't be skinny do skinny people stuff
if you won't be rich to rich people
stuff figure out what are the actions I
mean think about what a poor people do I
know poor people sometimes get stepped
on by other people I know they get
kicked I when I was broke I got people
stepping all over me I got lost still
got boot prints on my back from the way
some stupid bankers treated me I
understand sometimes there's oppression
from the outside I understand sometimes
you are a quote disadvantaged I am not
mad about that I just don't want you to
stay there regardless so stay out of the
payday lender you notice they don't put
payday lenders and riche into town you
know why because rich people wouldn't go
in there ever they would starve to death
before they went in there paid 800
percent interest they don't see tote the
note lights do you you don't see rent to
own do you lotto tickets some 75 to 80
percent of lotto tickets are purchased
in lower-income zip codes apparently
it's not a rich people thing if winning
the lotto was a wealth the way to riches
you'd see people with Rolexes standing
in line they drove up in a Mercedes or
they'd pay somebody stand in line for
them rich people don't play the lotto
honey Oh occasionally a few of you do
but it's just a throwback from back when
you were poor in general
rich zip coats don't sell a lot of
lottery tickets well they don't need it
no they figured out it doesn't work
stupid it doesn't work this is not
rocket science payday lending doesn't
work for you it makes them rich or to
rich people do they buy nice items high
quality items used and they pay cash and
they buy the item for their own use and
utilitarian value not to show off they
drive a two-year-old or older Mercedes
or Beemer because they don't really care
what you think they might drive a twenty
five-year-old one because they don't
care what you think they don't live in a
house for you they live in a house for
them they don't want vacations selling
put it on Facebook and show you they go
on vacations for them they don't live to
impress other people big hat no cattle
that's what they say in Texas about
people living to impress other people
stop acting rich stop it so you won't be
rich to rich people stuff I don't care
where you start that's your only shot
baby it's the only variable you can
control we can't control Washington we
can't control prejudice we can't control
politics we can't control the structural
problem through the economy but you can
control your freakin choices you'll get
to choose don't fall into the
hopelessness of fatalism it's a broken
diseased religion and it'll kill your
but this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]